- C'est un Suédois qui a
remporté le Nobel de médecine
cette année : le généticien
Svante Pääbo, qui n'était pas
sur la courte liste
des possibles nobélisables.
Sa contribution scientifique
est tout de même remarquable.
Il a littéralement inventé
la paléogénomique, l'étude
des gènes des espèces humaines
disparues.
C'est Svante Pääbo et
son équipe de l'Institut
allemand Max Planck qui ont
à séquencer pour
la première fois l'ADN
d'un homo neanderthalis,
une espèce éteinte depuis
près de 40 000 ans,
et à démontrer qu'une partie
de l'humanité est
de 2 % de gènes provenant
des Néanderthaliens.
On a d'ailleurs découvert
tout récemment que la COVID
semble frapper plus sévèrement
les gens qui sont porteurs
de gènes de Néanderthaliens,
essentiellement des Européens et
certains groupes d'Asiatiques.
Svante Pääbo, qui a aussi
participé à la découverte
d'une autre espèce disparue,
l'homme de Denisova, a reçu
une somme équivalente
à plus de 1,2 million dolla
canadiens avec son prix Nobel.
Le père du chercheur suédoisa x
Nobel de médecine, en 1982,
pour des recherches liées
aux hormones.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Mon